thank you is such an honor to be here
presenting the award for our final
category narrative film um previous
witness here at our student Oscars have
been Robert Robert Zemeckis
and Spike Lee hopefully the night's
winners will be following in their
footsteps particularly when it comes to
creating these landmark roles for young
actors like myself we got to stick
together yeah we all we got and um with
the whopping nine hundred and twenty
entries this year here are the top three
for narrative films day one by Henry
Hughes yeah yeah yeah yeah from the
American Film Institute in California
inspired by a true story of an Afghan
American woman working as a US military
interpreter must go beyond the call of
duty when a bomb makers wife goes into
labor
stealth by Bennett Lassiter what up babe
no making finger institute tell the
story of a childhood transgender child
who has to decide to run away or face
life as our true self
after a friend's betrayal and this way
up by Derek Lowe from American Film
Institute a homeless man enlists of a
teenage vagrant to keep his daughter
from finding out exactly what's going on
and he's really like